the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so today I'll talk about payment
channels and the Lightning Network and I
am sorry if I gloss over things I've
explained this like a lot in the last
two years because that's sort of my work
on so I might like to skip over
something you're like wait how did you
get there so let me know so it'll have
unidirectional payment channels and then
lightning channel and then multi-hop
okay
so the idea of payment channels why do
we need to do all this complicated weird
stuff with payment channels well the
problem is these networks are really
poor in scalability right every
transaction on the blockchain
you know that whole idea doesn't scale
it's sort of people say it's o of N
squared depends on what you define as N
and things like that right so if you
double the number of nodes it actually
doesn't you can say well if you double
the number of nodes each node is gonna
be making some transactions right and
then you're like okay yeah that's N
squared if you count the total number of
computations throughout the entire
system but at the same time it's like
well you've doubled the number of nodes
so really it's o of n right like for any
one computer your amount of computation
you have to do scales with how many
other computers that are so it's a
little you know questionable but but
basically it doesn't scale well right it
doesn't scale to what you want and so I
put a little history the first response
of anyone ever referring to Bitcoin so
there was a 2008 like October 30
Halloween 2008 or like maybe after
midnight so November 1st and Satoshi
wrote I've been working on a new
electronic cash system that's fully
peer-to-peer with no trusted third party
he has a little blurb the first reply on
this mailing list was some guy James a
Donald saying we very very much need
such a system the way I understand your
proposal it does not seem to scale to
the required size so that was the first
thing anyone's ever said about Bitcoin
and we're still talking about it almost
10 years later
I wonder who James Donnell is maybe he's
got a ton of Bitcoin now and he you know
mined it this was so it was written
about in late 2008 the actual software
was released in 2009
and no one really there's a couple males
no one really looked into it much okay
so you can start with a one way payment
channel and this was I think Satoshi
sort of mentioned these ideas never
really implemented anything and this the
way he talked about it didn't actually
work some people in 2012 I remember
looking at this I think blue mat and
Mike Hearn gave a talk about like how
you could make payment channels that
didn't quite work either but the idea
made sense so the idea is you have some
kind of shared balance between two
parties and you can move coins in one
direction without making new
transactions on the blockchain
so one thing we haven't looked at but
you might have seen in in the homework
so if you look at like a transaction
right probably have seen this kind of
thing through the homework it's got a
lock time and in this case the lock time
is zero that means this transaction is
valid
at any point you know above height zero
it's it's valid and every block is above
height zero you can also find
transactions which let's see yeah
which has a lock time of this so this
looks like a unix time where you you set
a time this is like a unix time so you
next time if you don't know it's like a
30 well its seconds since january 1st
1970 that's sort of like the you know
first second and i don't know that's
probably a week ago or something so you
can you can have that filled in a
transaction and the idea is the
transactions only valid after that time
or height it's a little weird below what
is it 500 million it counts as a height
above 500 million it counts as a you
next time which ends up working because
the idea the UNIX times below 500
million or like in the 80s so you
there's no Bitcoin didn't exist then
there's no real need to have time walk
think what's her about what five hundred
million yeah a couple thousand years so
ya know there's there's way more
problems than Bitcoin before that the
the time field in the headers for bytes
so either so if it was signed it be 2038
that it flips over and goes negative but
it's unsigned so you got till 2000 106
there's actually a hard fork to fix that
but so it you know there's there's all
sorts of weird like wait what do we do
in the hundreds or thousands of years we
have to make these little tweaks which
hopefully wouldn't be super
controversial because it's like well
it'll stop working unless we change this
little thing okay so yeah that you can
have these lock times and you can use
those so what you can do is make a
channel and a channel is really just a
multi-sig output multi-sig a lot of
times is used for I want to say
two-factor authentication but you know
you could have two of two multi-sig
where your phone needs to sign and your
desktop needs to sign and then if
someone steals your phone or you know
hacks your phone and gets the key out
well they have to also get your computer
so this is useful but in these cases
it's sort of adversarial multi-sig where
it's not just you and you it's not like
your phone and your computer it's okay
it's Alice and Bob they're completely
separate people they're not necessarily
friends you know it could be customer
merchants kind of thing and they create
a transaction together so they fund it
and Alice is funding this channel and so
she takes her own coins write her own TX
ID index her an output signs it and
sends to an allison bob multi-sig and
sends ten coins so in order to spend
this they both have to cooperate um but
before doing this Bob gives her a refund
transaction so the idea is if Alice just
broadcasts to this it says okay I'm
taking my coins I'm sending it to Alice
and Bob multi-sig Bob can just disappear
and then Alice is stuck and the money
stuck there forever because Bob
never sign or Bob can say Oh Alice looks
like you sent ten coins how about this
I'll give you nine of them you just give
me one of them and I don't you know
you're not buying anything this is just
I'm holding your coins hostage
Bob could even make a even better threat
and say I will sign a bunch of time lock
transactions if you want your money
today you only get one coin if you want
your money in a week you'll get two
coins and and you know sign these things
with lock times and all the transactions
over to Alice and say well you can pick
you know how long do you want to wait to
get your money back
an analysis only response is oh shoot
well if I wait years maybe I'll get most
of my coins back but if I want my money
now
you know there's there's all sorts of
horrible hostage situations even if
they're both if they both have money at
stake one one person could have less
time value of money so they're like look
I don't I don't need this anytime soon
so I'm willing to wait so this is
dangerous so what they do beforehand is
Alice's hey Bob give me a refund
transaction so Bob signs a refund
transaction with a lock time of one week
from now March 28th and the input is the
fund transaction ID even though the fund
transaction ID comes later
thanks to segue you can say I know what
the TX ID is gonna be I'm gonna you know
reference a spend for that and Bob
signature is gonna be on there bob signs
it hands it over to Alice Alice's
doesn't Alice's signatures not there yet
right so Alice can sign it and store it
on her drive or chicken sign later but
until March 28th this transactions not
happening right if you try to broadcast
it everyone will reject it and the
output from this refund transaction is
it just sends to Alice's address all 10
points yes
Oh how does how do they know the fun its
exid Alice can calculate it and tell Bob
Alice can say I'm building a fund
transaction Alice knows her inputs she
knows she doesn't actually have to sign
it all because the TX ID wasn't won't
contain the signature and those you know
what their key is so Alice can compute
the TX ID and tell Bob hey sign this you
know this is what the transactions gonna
look like
sign it and Bob right at this point has
no no risk Bob I guess needs to make
sure that he's not inadvertently signing
his own money right so if Alice says hey
here's the TX ID Bob should make sure
okay this is not my TX ID right but it's
actually doesn't matter since since he
sort of commits to Alice's funky here so
even if you've swapped the TX ID when
you sign you're signing off of what to
you say this is two of two multi-sig so
if this was Bob's single key it wouldn't
it wouldn't even work yeah so but so
Alice sort of has to give some
information about Bob signs hands the
refund over to Alice then Alice is able
to create this fun transaction and now
Alice's risk is minimized because she
says okay I'll send this to this channel
and worst case after wait a week right
if Bob disappears as soon as I broadcast
this
well then Bob's gone I can't do anything
we can't sign but then next week I'll be
able to use this transaction and get all
my money back yes
yes which which transaction so there's
there's the fund and the refund right no
it needs to be created before the the
fund right so it's not gonna be on the
network but Bob creates this first signs
it and gives it to Alice that way Alice
knows well I have this that will be
valid in a week and so that means it's
safe to sign and broadcast this you know
it's got Bob's signature and that's what
hand you hand over and then Alice can
sign later she can sign it immediately
on reception and their store it or she
can sign it on March 28th but the idea
she's got Bob's signature endorsing this
and it's not valid yet but she knows
minimized risk right
worst case wait a week okay so then what
can you do with this you can make sort
of similar to refund transactions but
they give Bob more money so you make two
outputs you say okay it's I'm spending
the fun transaction ID I put Alice's
signature and I say Alice gets nine
coins Bob gets one coin and Alice hands
that over to Bob right so you make a
transaction like that right it spends
the fun transaction output Alice and
Bob's he is but are both needed and
Alice signs this and says okay I get
nine you get one hands it over to Bob
and Bob says basically I just got the
money
I can broadcast this if I want right
Bob's got Alice's signature Bob can add
his signature broadcast this transaction
and receive one Bitcoin okay but see Bob
doesn't sign his side in broadcast Bob
just waits Bob's like cool I've got this
coin I'm not even gonna sign and
broadcast this
I know it's as good as having received
the actual coin because there's no
there's
thing else Alice can do on her own right
she can't take these ten coins she can
eventually get the refund in a week but
for now
Bob's safe and then maybe a day later
Alice says okay
I'm giving you another coin right I'm
what I'm doing is I'm signing a new
transaction it spends the same output
this is still you know this is still
there these have not been broadcast but
in this one
Alice gets eight coins Bob gets two
coins Alice signs it hands that over to
Bob bobs like great I got another coin I
will also just wait Bob can actually
delete this because well this is better
right for from Bob's perspective I'd
rather have two then one and there's no
any of them are valid right according to
the network the network itself no one's
seen these things they're not broadcast
only this exists as an output and you
can keep doing this right you keep doing
this as many times as you want well
within limits right what what's the
obvious limit here yeah sure
once once once Bob gets all ten there's
no reason to keep it open anymore also
you can't you can't reverse right if you
try if Alice says oh well so Alice Alice
always sort of sending money if Bob says
hey I'm gonna give you some money back
and Bob signs something say hey no I
have two coins and you have eight coins
I was like yeah but you have this right
you have this you out you know Alice
seven Bob three transaction I know you
can broadcast that whenever you want so
there's no credible way for Bob to say
like oh I'm giving you the money back in
this channel right yes she gave one two
and three
and the next one she gets about 2.5 and
yeah Bob Bob wouldn't bob would just
ignore it right Bob would be like yeah
but I already have three why would I
want two and a half right like and and
it's it's more like in that case if
Alice says oh I have to you know Alice
is trying to take some money back
essentially Bob is paying Alice in that
case but it's not credible right alice
is like yeah I can sign this again or I
can sign I have all ten again but you
know Bob's idea is like I'm just gonna
sign the one where I get the most money
so so that's you know that's a
limitation that's it's one direction
right you Alice can keep paying Bob Bob
can't pay back but that's still pretty
useful in some cases if you're have some
kind of recurrent payment you're
streaming videos or something you open a
channel you can keep paying one thing
that's nice is these can be really fast
so this you have to actually wait till
it's in the blockchain but these
transactions there's no blockchain
involved you just sign it and hand it
over to the other party and as soon as
they've received it they're like it I
got the money so this can be very low
latency so this is pretty cool there are
limitations right anyway so yeah Bob
keeps getting these half signed
transactions with more and more money
going to him
the old ones are useless right why would
I keep this old transaction where I got
one coin just delete it so Bob only
actually has to store one thing Bob also
has to be very careful though he's got a
sign and broadcast one of these before
next week if he doesn't
Alice can just broadcast the refund
transaction and you know he thinks he's
getting three coins but Alice's like no
I'm just taking all ten back and I was
like shoot I just you know got ripped
off and so you know from the network's
point of view the Bitcoin networks point
of view they no-one's seen any of this
right all they see is the fun
transaction nothing happens for days and
then they see one of these payment
channel closing transactions and they
might see multiple right Bob could
broadcast all three it would be dumb Bob
Bob willing wants this one but you know
you're basically using double spends to
create these channels okay so yes
yeah you if it happens that means either
Bob went down or Bob never you know like
it's all it's it should never use it in
real life right it's insurance so that
you you're not you're not worried that
Bob's just gonna run off and get your
phone right but you can't keep using the
chin like like at that point there's so
much trust involved right if you keep
trying to use the channel after the
weeks gone by Bob now see like it's the
same reason you can't make it
bi-directional right if Bob says hey
here's a transaction where you get more
more of the money Alice's like yeah but
that's not that's not credible right
because I know you can broadcast and
take more and similarly if Alice says
let's just keep the channel open Bob's
like no that's not credible right like I
know you can just take all the money at
any time so you handing me these new
signatures like it's it's sort of
meaningless it's not like there's so
much trust involved it like why bother
with this whole payment channel thing
right so this this is nice in that you
don't have to trust the counterparties
the worst they can do is disappear they
can't I mean yeah they can hurt
themselves right Bob can broadcast this
after this exists and now this is like
okay that was dumb thanks for the two
coins back or Bob can just disappear and
now it's like hey I'm gonna do the
refund like I know I'm you know you're
supposed to get these three coins but
you're gone and the refunds my only
option so I'm broadcasting it so you
don't have to worry about who is your
counterparty and you don't have any like
debt
there's no custody or anything like that
so that's really nice if you if you you
can add trust but we already have that
with like coinbase in the gemenon you
know the exchanges okay so this is
pretty useful time limits limits on you
know back and forth refund transactions
you have to be built before the trend
the fun transaction because and so
malleability hurts that right before seg
wit this was very risky slushy couldn't
do it
the refund transaction has to spend the
fun transaction and you don't really
know without segue you don't know what
that transaction ladies gonna be before
it gets brought it gets confirmed and so
you could try to anticipate oh well
there might it might get Molly ated to
these five different things let's do it
but it's risky right so so let's segue
it's nice you know what to worry about
okay so any questions about the sort of
simple
One Direction payments makes sense okay
so how can you make it even better
what if you want to make it
bi-directional and last forever that
would be much more useful right but like
it's a tricky problem the refund
transactions there and the clock's
ticking also how do you delete or revoke
these old transaction right if you've
signed over okay you've got eight coins
I've got two coins that's there forever
and the blockchain doesn't know that
it's not valid anymore right the whole
point of the blockchain is to say okay
this is gone actually but between this
unidirectional and lightning I think how
did the order go like christian decker
wrote a thing about decrementing time
locks and i don't think he published I
think he published after we wrote
lightning but the idea was like these
would have lock times it's like you
could broadcast this you could broadcast
this on the 27th right all the three of
these could be broadcast on the 27th and
then the idea is Bob wants to send money
back and you put a lock time on the 26th
and the idea is like oh now now there's
these all are 27th but now there's a bob
to alice 8 over here that's broadcast on
the 26th and so the idea is well Alice
can get the money back you know Alice
Bob can pay and go back to paying Alice
because it's like sooner and now it's
gonna like race so that helps a little
and that you can switch back and forth a
few times but each time you do it the
time window gets like sooner so that's
kind of cool idea
but I think the Lightning one is nicer
because it like makes it okay whoa the
goal is back and forth between these two
parties and lasts forever and you can do
as many transactions as you want okay so
how do you do that so there's two timing
op coats that have been added to Bitcoin
and like check sequence verifies is
pretty much for lightning in my opinion
that's that's the real use case there's
also check check lock on verify so the
idea of sequence verify is it's a
relative lock time so it doesn't specify
okay this transactions valid on March
28th it says this transactions valid
when the input is spending is a week old
and by a week oh that's you know it's in
a week's worth of blocks in the actual
software we we don't usually use time we
always use block ight it's sort of
simpler to think about in a lot of ways
but you can say okay well this you know
this I sent to an output script and the
output script specifies that you can
only spend this these coins after the
transaction creating them has been you
know in a hundred block you know a
hundred blocks deep so that's kind of an
interesting useful thing requires yeah
in confirmations if not you can't spend
it I've checked long time verify it's a
lot absolute long time off code so you
require that the transaction be
confirmed at high ten or or above and
the difference between so what we said
in the fund
sorry the refunds transaction the refund
transaction the transaction field has a
lock time right so in this case here but
the transaction itself has a long time
and the OP but that's that's different
from the OP code the what the off code
does it says okay this output has a lock
time because the output script ensures
that the transaction itself has a long
time right so basically what this off
you know it says you say OP check lock
time verify five hundred thousand and
then it checks that the transactions
lock time field is exactly equal to five
hundred thousand
so it's a way to enforce a transaction
wide-field inside of an output it's a
little weird but both of these become op
codes that you can use in scripts and
now you can specify like a make an
address that has these weird timing
properties okay any questions about
these two yep
you can mix them and match them check
sequence verify is specific to an input
so there's a sequence field in each
input that was completely useless until
like I said what well okay so if you
look there's like a sequence and it was
always just ffffff you know that's like
2 to the 32 or whatever 2 to the 32
minus 1 I think and it didn't do
anything Satoshi put it in because he
thought ok this will this will let you
indicate finality right where you can
increment the sequence number so you say
ok this is sequence 1 and then I can
replace it with sequence 2 and it didn't
work because you can't have consensus on
those things so this was a field that
was sort of unused in the inputs and
what they did is they said ok we'll make
that a sequence number where if you now
make this say you make the sequence
number a hundred for example and then in
your transaction it'll say ok this this
this TX you know this transaction output
that you're spending is it a hundred
blocks old and if so we're good if not
this input spending fails so it's
another check in addition to the
signature and then you can also ensure
that that with the width check sequence
verify you can put in the opcodes you
can put in the script ok this must have
a sequence of 100 and then check that
the sequence is equal you know equal or
greater to the you know depth of the
transaction and yet you can mix them and
match them in the same script it's a
little ugly to use because it was
introduced as a soft work and they they
renamed and opted not write a no op op
got renamed to this this is like no op3
and so you have to push the the number
you're checking on the stack up check
sequence verify and then you have to
drop the number off the stack because it
the this opcode doesn't actually consume
anything off the top of the stack so
that it looks the same as a no op two
nodes that don't know about it anyway so
you've got these two ways to specify
output timing okay good so then what you
can do is you can revoke based on timing
so the idea of the script and this is
sort of in like see like notation not
the actual op codes for Bitcoin because
the actual op codes are kind of
confusing the idea is okay you can spend
with two of two multi-sig essentially
right key a and key B or GC and wait a
hundred blocks and buy wait a hundred
blocks that means that this you know
whatever you're spending has to be a
hundred blocks you know confirmed a
hundred blocks ago or more so a and B
two that together they can spend any
time they want secant it's together oops
see you can spend but must wait and a
and B can grab the coins first so this
is a revocable transaction so the idea
is you've got some and we call it a
commitment transaction in the lightning
paper you've got some input the funding
transaction output you're spending that
you've got you need to of to multi-sig
so like Bob's signs and sends it over to
Alice and then you've got that script
where it's okay it's Alice's key and you
wait a hundred blocks or Alice's key and
you make a new key for Bob like the Bob
revoke key and this has two coins this
has eight coins
Oh oops this should be our hold on I
should change that that's kind of gonna
be really confusing wait
I put the R in the wrong place let me
redo that's that's a typo but it's super
confusing yeah
Elessar and Bob Allison wait did I so
put the same thing on both right this
wood is Alice R and Bob yeah and there's
like when you're actually coding this
stuff it's pretty easy to screw up
there's a lot of like wait who's Allison
who's Bob so I don't in any of the code
I don't use Allison Bob I use like mine
and theirs but a lot of times it's not
clear because it's like held by us so
this is the transaction that Bob creates
Bob signs transfer balance and then it
sits on Alice's hard drive yes okay so
you don't you make these these separate
keys right it's it's a key that Alice
creates right Alice creates another pub
key pair and tells the pub key to Bob it
says and this is her sort of revocable
key yeah where Alice kinland basically
what else house is house gives the
private key to Bob in order to revoke
this transaction so there's sort of
mirror images in both cases both parties
agree look Alice has got two coins Bob's
got eight coins
right but the transaction that Bob
creates and signs yes the transaction
that Bob creates and signs sends Bob
eight coins in the clear this is just a
regular old pay to pub key hash where
Bob gets eight coins the coins that are
Alice's though Alice has to wait a
hundred blocks if she broadcasts this
commitment transaction
she can't spend her money for a day like
a hundred block whatever a hundred block
day Bob can get the money but only if he
knows Alice's are key Alice's were you
know revocable key so you know Alice has
this Bob doesn't and in the Bob case
it's similar
you know the outputs are the same but
the ideas Alice creates this Alice signs
it
hands it over to Bob and in this case
the transaction is well Alice gets two
coins in the clear right
this is immediately spendable no fancy
scripts or anything Bob gets the money
but he has to wait a day or Alice can
spend the money if she knows Bob's
revocable key this Bob our key right so
either party at any time can broadcast
these transactions the thing is the
money they're supposed to get right so
in in Bob's case Bob can add Bob's
signature broadcast but now he has to
wait no big deal wait a hundred blocks
okay in Alice's case okay she can close
it and you know put her signature on
here broadcast wait a day spend the
money but what's nice is you can revoke
it right so Alice can say look I'm Alice
can tell Bob I'm not gonna do this I'm
not going to use this transaction the
way I'll prove it to you the whale you
know I deleted it and Bob's like yeah
sure you deleted the way I'll prove you
that I deleted this is I will tell you
the private key I'll tell you Alice R so
now you Bob knows Bob because Bob
actually Bob created this transaction
right Bob signed it Bob knows what it
looks like and Bob knows well yeah this
is the script since Bob knows Alice R
and Bob knows his own key Bob Noah's
look this money's mine this money's mine
to write because I can do this
immediately so if you brought this
transaction I don't have to even touch
this because it's just my money and this
output I can spend immediately well you
have to wait a hundred blocks so and you
know my software's gonna automatically
do that so I know Alice R its private
key I know Bob's private key I just take
these two coins as soon as I see this
transaction I take these two coins I
spend them back to Bob's address and get
all 10 so that's a pretty convincing way
for Alice to say look I'm not gonna use
this I'm deleting and to show you know
even if I do use it here here's the key
okay any questions about this yep yeah
so Alice has to hand it over right this
is just a regular you know 32 byte
private key
that Alice created and similar you know
same idea for Bob they both create you
know essentially the same transaction
but with things swapped Bob Bob can
broadcast this if he does he has to wait
a day but if he reveals Bob Bob our
private key to Alice Alice knows okay I
get two coins in the clear and then
these eight coins I can sign this I can
sign this I can get these eight coins
immediately Bob's got away today so
that's a way to sort of say look I'm not
going to use this any other questions
okay so what you do with that is yeah
either party can broadcast that to wait
they exchange these revoked and
revocation private private keys and now
if they broadcast the counterparty can
take all the funds so it's pretty pretty
good so the idea is this is a lightning
channel you've got this output you
create these states okay the first state
is Alice gets one coin Bob gets nine
coin then what Bob wants to pay Alice so
Bob says hey Alice I'm paying you for
coins here I'll sign and create this new
output this new transaction in it to
Alice and Bob's and Alice says okay but
now we have to revoke this one right
we've got you know Alice has this it's
signed Alice can broadcast it but Alice
also wants to be sure that Bob can't
broadcast this anymore so they sort of
trash it right they reveal there are
private keys to each other so in
practice right it could be well only Bob
has to reveal the our private key in
this case because Alice is never going
to well you know alice is gonna
broadcast this not this it's just so
much simpler if they both if they both
reveal the R keys because then you don't
have to worry about like something you
know what happens in the future when
Alice has 0.5 and Alice still has this
thing so it's really simple you just
they both reveal and now this
transaction this state one it's
basically on broadcast you know you're
not gonna use it and they can keep doing
that and they can go back and forth
right so now Alice phase Bob says hey or
no oops
go back and forth oh well oops anyway
you can you can make this like Alice
back to two and Bob back to eight or
whatever you know basically arbitrary
numbers you can keep going in both
directions and you know deleting the old
old so that's pretty useful there's no
lock time for the transact for the
channel itself the channel can just keep
going on forever and Alice and Bob can
keep sending these things it's a little
more complicated I didn't put yeah I
didn't put the the messages but they
have to send four more messages you can
optimize it to three because right so if
you've Alice and Bob the first thing
they do is Alice sends a signature so
let's say they're you know they're at
state five okay so she says here's a
signature for state six and Bob says
okay I'll give you a signature for state
six so now they both build state six
alright they've let's say you know go
from five to six and then Alice can say
okay I'll give you your you know
revocation key for state five and then
Bob can say okay I'll give you a
revocation keep for Steve five and then
they're done right then they've you know
they've created the new state and
revoked the old state you can't squish
really if Alice cannot put Rev five here
in the same message do you know why it
why not so yeah well yeah Rev key just
yeah abbreviate to Rev so why would this
be bad if Alice says look here's state
six and I'm revoking my claim on state
five what what goes wrong if you do that
no quiet Bob Bob broadcasting states
sticks is okay in that case so you do
that no because he doesn't he doesn't
because because because state five is
not broadcast right only Alice can sign
in broadcast state five so the problem
with this is if you do this Bob's fine
alice is stuck right because Alice does
not have state six on her drive right
all Alice has on her drive is state five
and she's just revealed the key for
state five to revoke it so basically
like alice has nothing at this point and
Bob can just wait analysis stuck and
then that's that's a really good
position for Bob to be in because Bob is
like hey I can close the channel I can
close the channel at state five or state
six probably he wants state six if
usually you know you're sending money
but I can close this channel and you can
so give me some money you know you can
close you know close the channel that
kind of that's the attack right right
and and you want it on your side right
so this is creating a new state for Bob
but it's revoking the old state for
Alice if you want you do this so that's
dangerous for you know Alice doesn't
want to do that so the simplest way is
okay create the new state by signing six
revoking five revoking five you can
optimize this though right can you guys
see the reduces the three messages yeah
he can send SIG's SIG's SIG's we have
five at the same time so you get down
into three messages so that's cool it's
you know basically here's state six
okay here's state six and I revoke my
claim on say five okay overflow point
claim let's say five then they both
update their you know once this happens
the UI is finished
you end up it ends up being faster if
you pre generate like one key ahead
where you say like hey here's the next
public key I'm gonna use all so that
it'll do so that I can write cuz Alice
one she's building state six she needs
to know Bob's a revocation key in the
state six so you pre share like one or
two steps ahead so that you don't have
to say hey can you get me into the next
key okay you know otherwise you'd have
this message where it's like request
state six key send it send the signature
back so there's all there's like more
data in these messages but that like
optimize yeah yeah so so you also put
some public keys in here in this this is
the private key yes in here right you're
sending the signature but you can also
send here's how much I'm giving you
here's what the times and stuff are most
of it can be computed because the
transactions don't change that much
right the scripts are the same everyone
knows what this is gonna look like so
you don't have to actually send too much
data another optimization didn't put in
is you're gonna potentially have to
retain all of these are private keys so
if you make a million states and you
know you and 900 you know whatever are
revoked Bob has to keep track of all
those million old Alice private keys
analysis to keep track of all those old
Bob private keys that's kind of annoying
not the end of the world but it's like
32 bytes each can be a couple hundred
megabytes if you use this channel a lot
so you can make this so I thought I came
up with it but at the same time when I
was coming up with it I was like no I'm
I'm pretty sure this isn't some paper
somewhere and I can't find it and then
talking to people here apparently like
it's a gold wasö it likes a professor
here came up with it in like the 80s I
called it L chrome because spelled
backwards it's Merkel right
so you have a binary tree and you say
like ok 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 is the root for
example and when you want to when you
want to descend to the left you take the
value here append and L or like maybe
you know 0 is left and one is right or
something or L or R and you hash it so
you say ok I'm taking this value
sticking something on hashing to get
down here and similarly you know through
here you make a big tree the idea there
is you can reveal things sequentially
and say ok I reveal 0 fine I'll store it
I'll reveal one store it I reveal two
now you can delete 0 1 because you know
the parent and you can compute 0 and 1
from knowing to right so I give you 1 0
give you 1 give you 2 you believe 0 1
then I give you 3 4 5 you delete 3 & 4
then I want to give you 6 you delete 2 &
5 so that way you only have to store or
log in secrets right but when you know
you can't give in 0 & 1 you can't
compute 2 and given 3 you know two three
and four you can't compute 5 or 6 but
once you've got them you can compute all
the old ones so if we do that for the
the secret Keys that like reduces
storage a lot so that's kind of a nice
optimization it's pretty quick and then
so then you basically your your total
data that you're storing for these
channels never gets more than like a
kilobyte or two so that's pretty useful
ok other questions on this this alone
actually is really complicated like yeah
so there is a there is a sort of like
superposition time here right we're at
time so let's say this is x 0 this is
time 1 this is time to this time 3 so at
time 1 Bob's got a got two states he can
broadcast right Bob's like I can do six
or five
Alice can only broadcast five but Alice
knows that Bob can broadcast six right
so Alice is also like well I'm not sure
which it is if it's if I if you know
from Alice's perspective if I close I'm
gonna stay five if Bob closes he's at
state six and then at state two Alice
can only broadcast state six but Bob can
broadcast sorry Alice can broadcast
either but Bob can only broadcast one so
yet during this process there's sort of
it's not clear which state it is and you
know if something happens like you know
Bob goes offline you know Alice sends
SIG's signature for six and Bob goes
offline then it's like okay I never got
a response I'll just try to close at
state five I guess right and then I
guess that payment never went through
but then Bob could say no I got it and
broadcast it like so that you know
things can get weird where you're not
really sure what happens here so like
it's more a UI issue where in the UI
like only show things after you get to
the end hopefully in most cases this
whole process takes a fraction of a
second right because you're just sending
some messages to each other so that's
the nice part that's sort of the
Lightning II thing is fast
right
Yeah right so they they're sending
messages to each other they can't they
can't really pre-compute these things
because they don't know how much money
is getting sent back and forth right so
so when you're signing state six you're
also signing the the value the output
values and when Bob receives state six
and signs his version of state six he
also is like you know I don't know how
much money I'm getting yet so I need to
sign off on that
so yeah both parties need to be online
to receive which is different than
normal in Bitcoin that's the same as
that's the same as the unidirectional
payment channels in the unidirectional
one will were Bob the receiver he
doesn't have to sign but he still has to
be online because the the transaction
just goes directly to him it doesn't go
on to the blockchain right none of these
are publicly known okay yes well what if
what if you know this was state one
right where Alice had one and bob had
nine and then state you keep going and
Bob keep in general the general trend is
Bob's losing money right Bob's okay you
know you go back and forth but at the
end bob has one Bob needs to worry that
Alice holds on to state one and then
months later broadcasts it while Bob's
not watching and then there's no right
way no opposite Alice has to worry about
Bob broadcasting state one in the future
right but so you still need to keep the
secret though it's revoked but that
reveil the whole process of revocation
is Bob gives a key to Alice
so if Bob forgets that key then sorry if
Alice forgets this key Bob can broadcast
it and then Alice can't grab it yeah
they can broadcast yeah they can anyone
can brought so from the network's
perspective these are all equally valid
the network has no idea which came when
and or anything like that the only way
you enforce it is you know Bob broadcast
this alice is like oh I'm taking this
fund cuz I have the key so that's that's
also a
you know a pretty significant different
security model it's a it's a security
reduction right now you have to actively
defend your channel because you if
you're if you go offline I'm Alice I'm
supposed to have nine coins I go on
vacation I turn off my computer and Bob
knows I've turned off my computer then
I'll you know Bob can say Oh Alice is
out like this this 100 block delay she's
not gonna be online I'm just gonna
broadcast this get the nine coins wait a
hundred blocks and then you know sweep
them as soon as I can
and then Alice comes back plugs in and
it's like oh you were wait no I
oh it says I lost eight coins what
because broad Bob defrauded so you have
to be online I'm not I think I'm gonna
get into it next time there's a way to
outsource that so that you don't have to
be watching you can have someone else
watch for you and I'll probably talk
about that next time but in the last 20
minutes yeah so this is cool right this
is light network channels to parties
indefinite you still need to create a
channel to pay people so you just do one
on chain transaction to open the channel
wanted to close the channel potentially
two to close the channel but that's
pretty rare right if you need to
immediately grab it then you're time
sensitive and you're gonna have to
closing transactions if you closed
normally like you close the current
state you need to wait a hundred blocks
for your money to be active but you
don't have to spend it immediately after
that you can just leave it because you
know so so in this case let's say this
is Bob's Held's transaction Bob
broadcasts it Bob knows okay Alice gets
her two coins I get my eight coins I
have to wait a hundred blocks but I
don't actually have to spend it after a
hundred blocks I can just leave it in my
wallet because Bob knows he never gave
Alice this key so this this clause this
or Alice and Bob are key it's just not
gonna happen so Bob safe and just like
leaves it so he doesn't meet you know he
can just use that as well however if
it's the like no you
kind of thing then you have to do two
transactions that's Rhoda so this is
pretty good but you still have to do two
transactions so if you use this you open
a channel you use it once and then you
close it well that was dumb you just
paid twice as much on in fees that you
needed to so it's useful for some things
not for others could we do something
like multiple party channels so there's
research about this it gets real ugly
real fast like I want a single channel
with like three or four users or like a
tree of channels where the first top you
know output has 404 multi-sig and then
it branches into these two of two multi
six there's a lot of interesting ideas
but it gets a little ugly so like the
off chain scalability gets bad there's
like a lot of N squared kind of stuff so
what about a forwarding network of
point-to-point channels so okay if we
have these two party channels and people
are connected with them so Alice and Bob
have a channel and Bob and Carol have a
channel so this would be cool Alice can
just say hey Bob I will pay you if you
pay Carol and you can do that right
Alice says look I'm just making a new
state where you have an extra coin now
please give this extra going to Carol
and Bob says yeah okay it does so the
the the word there that should have
immediately raised like oh no that's not
how this stuff works is the word please
you don't say please in Bitcoin uh so
yeah the other option is Bob just keeps
it right so Alice says okay here I'll
you know add a coin to your output in
this in this channel and please add a
coin to Carol's output in your channel
with her and Bob says yeah no I'm just
gonna keep the coin thanks if your trust
so this this might not be super crazy in
that well you've got a channel with them
maybe they're merchants also you can you
can reduce the number of coins you send
per update right you can say look I'm
gonna send like one Satoshi at a time
and so worst case you keep one Satoshi
that you shouldn't have right you could
write it's
it's not a scalable though because let's
say you want to send a lot of money to
Carol okay you're gonna have to keep
doing these little things it's kind of
annoying also what if you want multiple
hops where you're not even sure who's in
the middle of your over your chain it
doesn't work for that okay so you can
have what's called HDFC's and these more
complicated okay
so the idea is it's hash time locked
contract or a hex time walk contract
whatever the script is essentially this
key a and preimage are you need to
present a pre-image of a hash or a key B
and some absolute lock time check lock
time verify it and it's it's important
that this is an absolute time not a
relative time because these should be
able to expire regardless of when they
get broadcast on to the blockchain so
the idea is in this case Alice so let's
say a is Alice B's Bob Alice gets the
money if she knows this preimage are
this 32 byte you know so what actually
goes here is the hash of our right it's
like it's like a pay to pub key hash
where you say up you know up hash 160 up
do pop hash 160 the thing people verify
so you need to know some preimage and
you need to sign or you can be Bob and
then you can sign after a certain you
know after a certain date so the way you
build these so this is kind of nice it's
like well if R is known then it's
Alice's money if R is unknown then it's
Bob's money after a certain period of
time okay
so this was the revocable transaction
right where okay Alice got two coins
Bob's got eight coins and then you add a
third output this hdl-c output we're
okay now Alice has two coins Bob has
seven coins and Alice might be getting
an extra coin if she learns our Bob gets
the coin back after height 500,000 right
so this is this similar to like when
this is like okay this is Bob's money
but if he does something bad Alice can
grab it
this is not
this is this is Alice's money if she
knows our if she doesn't Bob gets it
back so there's no like mallet Liam this
is sort of like really this is Bob's
money right this only happens if
something Horrible's you know someone's
trying to rip someone off this on the
other hand is well depends
does Alice gonna learn our or not and
what is our okay so the multi-party
adversarial payment model so the
lightning forwarding is Alice wants to
pay Carol right she doesn't want to just
ask Bob to keep forwarding the funds
because she doesn't trust Bob so she
connects to Carol and by connect I mean
like regular TCP connection and says hey
Carol make a random number R and send me
the hash codes okay here you go
Carol knows H which is the the hash and
R which is the pretty much she sends
over H to Alice Alice then says to Bob
hey I'm going to add an HDL C to our our
Channel so basically Bob if you know the
preimage of h if you know R you can get
this coin if not I get the coin back
after five o'clock and then Bob says
okay cool
I know H now but I don't know R so I
can't I can't grab this money right I
don't know this so there's no way this
is gonna be my money it's just gonna go
back to you after five and Alice says
yeah but you know Carol knows are so ask
Carol
Bob says okay I get it I will forward
this on to Carol and then I create a
similar output I make sure that these
are the same R or the same H I don't
know why yet but I say hey Carol if you
know R if you know the preimage of H you
can get this coin if not after four
o'clock I get the money back and then
Carol says oh cool
well guess what I know R because I made
up made made are up and I can
so from careless perspective Carol could
broadcast this on to the blockchain
immediately and she will be able to grab
the money right cuz she knows our she
has to grab it soon because by 4 o'clock
Bob can grab the money better than
closing that
and if carol if Carol does this she
closes the channel she uses our because
she knows it to take this coin from this
output Carol doing that will reveal art
to everyone in the world because it's on
the blockchain now
and so then Alice or certain that Bob
can say ah I know R now I need to get
this money so Bob can close the channel
grab the money yes this offer yeah we
use Heights you could do a time the the
reason we the main reason for Heights is
what if a blocks full and like height
height seems because Heights sort of
variable like maybe a bunch of blocks
come out quickly maybe they come out
slowly so time is a little dangerous in
that you could say okay four o'clock but
maybe in the next five hours only a
couple blocks come out just by chance
and they're full and you're not able to
broadcast you know and you're not able
to get this in then it's risky so the
height sort of takes into account the
variable nature of it a little bit
better yeah well page for parent yeah so
the question is well you know what if
the fees get really high right what if
these the thing is this whole process
should take a few seconds so it's not
like these outputs are have have weird
fees that are like old right one that
one issue is what if you're building
these states back and forth and then you
sit on one for a few weeks and then the
fee rate goes way up and you're like
shoot if I try to broadcast these
transactions the fees too low and it
might not get confirmed that's not it's
not a huge risk because if you're not
trying to rip people off you don't
actually have any time risk in this case
these this gets built this get spill
these are sort of in real time and so
you know what the fee rate is in the
network so you can see can adapt to it
but yeah that's not sure yeah
if some you know if you have like a
number of nodes you mean a minimal
number like
don't need global consensus in that I
didn't I did the only three so it you
can't show if you have four you can sort
of say let's say you have Alice Bob
Carol Dave um Carol doesn't it like you
don't actually have to know the whole
thing you just have to know the person
before you in the person after you you
don't care what the actual end points
are so to some extent Bob doesn't need
to know maybe Alice got this hdl-c
forwarded from someone else before and
Bob's like all I know is Alice's you
know I could get money from Alice I know
R and Carol gets it for me if she knows
R and if maybe that keeps going or
something
you don't need global consensus for this
yeah yeah you don't all you're all
you're only concerned with the channels
you're participating in if there's
something else happening before it you
might want to watch in case our shows up
but you know you don't have to worry
about it
and then like these along get broadcast
you know the sort of failure mode is
broadcast everything onto the blockchain
and let the blockchain sorted out and
that's you know that's very highly and C
because it's like ten minutes but the
blockchain you know the idea is the
blockchain already has that global
consensus because it's really low
latency and everyone can agree on it so
I think that's yeah so what you could do
here is you can just close it right you
could broadcast this whole transaction
on the blockchain
and get the payment through that's
really inefficient you want to keep your
channels open so what instead happens in
in you know when everything's working
the idea is it could happen right Carol
could just broadcast it okay that's
annoying whatever but no one loses money
or Carol can go offline at this point
and then these things get stuck you know
there's all sorts of weird things that
can go wrong you know lose money but
what happens when things go right is
Carol says hey um Bob I know are and so
really this whole crazy hdl-c thing it's
just my money right I know what R is
you're never you're not getting this
money
at 4 o'clock because I know our so here
look I'll tell you our and when Carol
tells Bob our she's doing two things
she's proving that this hdl-c is her
money she's also giving Bob our so that
he can then grab Alice's money and so as
soon as she reveals our to Bob Bob says
yeah I agree
this hdl-c is superfluous at this point
I know you know our so this is just your
money and you know if it gets close to 4
o'clock I know you're gonna broadcast
this channel onto the chain if I don't
let you clear it out so let's just make
a new state you know through these kind
of state updates where you just have the
extra money let's clear out that hdl-c
so that one coin goes to you
and goes like okay cool I agree we'll
sign this and they let's get rid of the
hdl-c output then Bob goes to Allison
says hey Alice guess what I know R so
this this part I'm gonna do it
I know R and Bob this Alice after 5
o'clock it's not happening right if you
if you stop if you stop answering me and
it gets to like 4:30 I'm just gonna
broadcast the the the channel on chain
and grab it that way and then out Bob
reveals our to Alice Alice's oh yeah you
do no heart okay will clear the hdl-c
out and you get the money and then Alice
gets R and that sort of a receipt for
the payment and Alice knows well carol
was the one who told me h carol must
have gotten the money right so that's my
my confirmation of that
oh so an input in the script but it's
it's revocable the same way everything
the the regular outputs are revocable
there's also this you don't even have to
do because the the idea is if the HDL
sees are very small in comparison with
the other outputs in the state that if
you try to broadcast an old one you'll
lose weigh more than the HDL see is
worth but you can also tack on a or
other Clause to the HDL C script with a
relative lock time so there's actually a
couple different ways to do it the
simplest is you just say look the other
the two you know I've got two coins
eight coins or two point seven coins and
then a one coin hdl-c I'm not gonna risk
my seven coins to go back and try to get
this one coin in the HLC but that's not
how most of the software does it you
just add a new clause okay so this is a
multiple party adversarial so yeah that
would be really useful right you you
build lots of nodes with channels
connecting and they form a big graph and
then you can sort of request payment
routing these these hdl-c outputs and if
you open a few channels then you can pay
lots of different users on the network
yes Bob kid charged a fee or he could
just be a nice guy
that's basically the
please yeah so yeah so you can pay him
um it's gonna be hard to pay him much
because alice is gonna say look we've
got a channel we're using it if you
charge me a ton to forward payments to
Carol I'm just gonna close the channel
and open with someone who does it
cheaper so yeah you can you can make the
amounts slightly less right so Allah
says I'm sending you one coin and Bob
says okay I'm sending 0.9999 coins to
Carol and I'm keeping the difference he
can have that and then it's really up to
Carol to decide if the fee because Alice
all Alice knows is hey I'm sending one
coin and then Carol sees what if Bob
puts a crazy fee like half a coin Carol
sees 0.5 and Carol is like no I that's
that's way too low I don't know what
happened if Alice sent 0.5 and Bob
forwarded it to me or if Alice sent one
and Bob Ford went five but I'm not
accepting this right I'm not gonna
reveal our to you I'm just gonna say no
so you can do that right at this point
Carol has not yet revealed are Carol can
refuse and say look at Bob I'm not gonna
accept this gauge steel see we can just
clear it out right away without
revealing our and and just basically
undo what we just did yeah two photos -
that the first is can there be a
situation where it's an efficient market
place for these
actually wins and she rots it from that
you can so if let's say Alice is
connected to like you know three three
Bob's in the middle and then asks all of
them hey what are you gonna charge me to
forward a coin to Carol
then they can all answer it's a little
weird because they can they can lie at
that point because I haven't actually
like signed anything and this fob can
say oh I'll do it for free and this Bob
says I'll do it for half a coin into
this bob says I'll do it a tenth of a
coin and then you try to go for the free
one and Carol gets like some really low
amount and says I'm not telling you are
let's let's cancel this and then you can
if Alice trusts Carol Cael can be like
Alice Bob just tried to charge a
ridiculous fee don't use this you know
this Bob is bad and then you try the
other Bob and the other Bob does the
right thing yeah open the channel so
yeah you could you just have to open a
channel yeah you have to go on chain so
the idea is long term like it we sort of
saw a preview of it in November December
January where it was actually kind of
expensive to use Bitcoin now it's cheap
again costs a few cents but for a month
or two it was like oh shoot like this
costs like five bucks to make a chain on
chain transaction and so like creating a
new direct channel from Alice to Carol
it might cost five bucks or it might
cost twenty bucks or you know like long
term if everyone's trying to use the
blockchain and the fees go really high
it could be kind of expensive and so the
idea is well if I've got a channel
already I'd rather use that and move my
money around that way without having to
like touch the blockchain yeah
so scalability so like you can sort of
so it's bone for it or it's like Jake's
Torres kind of if you know the whole
graph yeah well so that's one part is if
you know the whole graph and you you can
know the whole graph because the graph
never gets bigger than the UT Exocet
right every channel is a is a
transaction output and so if you're
running a full node and you have the
whole UT Exocet well the entire graph is
is on the order of that size so maybe
it's twice as big I mean that you have
to have some like extra metadata about
what these outputs are and like Bob and
Carol can make proofs they're like oh
here's our channel and it's in the UT
Exocet and we can sort of reveal our pop
keys that they go in here so if you have
the whole graph you can do some routing
that's like n log n kind of speed but
then it might not work and so that's the
like so there's lots of ways there's
there's actually tons of ways things can
go wrong in this that's the sort of fun
part of dealing with there's one of the
ways it can it cannot work is you're
like yeah I found a path the simplest is
I found a path and I query Bob and Bob
is just offline like oh okay well that's
not an active path ok what's the second
shortest fast ok this other Bob and and
he says yes but the fee seems really
high so ok I found the 30 so most of the
algorithms though will will get you like
the second and third and fourth and
fifth shortest in much less time than
recomputing the whole thing from scratch
so you can get a you can get a bunch of
pretty good ones and try them all by
query and they're what
yeah the thing is in practice it's all
real fast right like there's well right
now there's like you know for a small
Network it's nothing but even total
number of UT EXO's is on the order of
like millions right so if you've got a
graph with like millions of edges that's
that's easy for a computer right they'll
do it in like less than a second so and
then you that your main thing here is
network latency for all of these things
for for building new states it's the the
time taken for you know the data to get
from one side of the other is much
larger than computing the signatures
verifying the signatures building the
hash tree thing all that stuff is is
real fast compared to network so same
with routing looking at the look at the
graph and detecting it is gonna be
faster than contacting all the things
there's a bunch of other things that can
go wrong so for example this gets built
you get to here and just Carol the stops
responding right so now you've got these
two HDL sees there there a third output
in your channel transaction and Carol is
just like not saying anything and then
Alice goes to Bob it's like Bob what's
up like we're gonna clear the stage teal
see usually these only take a second and
Bob's like oh yeah hold on and so it's
kind of awkward right because now we've
got the same she'll seen you don't know
whose money it ends up being there's the
way to mitigate that that rusty yeah I
think it works
Rusty's other guy who works on this
stuff was that Alice were quite if he
has like a timeout period I think 30
seconds a minute whatever where Alice
says okay Bob I made this hdl-c a minute
ago minutes up you need to either shut
down this channel right now because
you're doing something bad or you need
to shut down you need to prove to me
that a channel has been shut down with
this hdl-c this h value in it and then I
know where to ascribe blame
so if Bob's like yeah I can't contact
Carol Carol's offline the analysis all
right well then shut down the channel
right
yeah
so it's that's the downside right well
thing is if you don't do that you can in
this world it's like being live really
matters okay
true okay one thing to mitigate that the
only time care this is this is a Carol
responded by signing off on the hdl-c
and then immediately goes offline like
so you know it's it's not like you
accident well part of the protocol is if
you have an HD LC and you don't remove
it within 30 to 60 seconds it's like you
know that's that's a violation of the
rules and we're gonna close your chant
there channels because if you're just
offline straight-up offline and it's
like well okay I'm not going to use that
channel but it's like oh I accepted this
and immediately said okay I'm not
talking you anymore and they're like
well now it's stuck because the the sort
of attack vector is build a ton of HDL
C's right you could have multiple per
channel
and like build them all and they all get
stuck and one party's just not
responding with there are values and
then everyone's like okay if we try to
close our transactions now have like 100
outputs and they're huge and have all
these fees also all these HDL sees yeah
there might be really little and we have
to like wait and then it charges a lot
of fees to recover them and stuff so you
don't you don't want people to be able
to sort of bloat the number of HDL CS in
your channels so the way to do it is
okay if one of them stuck you need to
find someone to blame and yeah it's it's
possible right but but the thing is you
you accurately find the person to blame
if Carol accepts the HDL C and then a
split second later unplugs their
computer Bob's like wow okay fine I'm
closing the channel you just did
something really annoying and if I don't
you know Bob's like if I don't close
this channel Alice isn't gonna close the
channel on me because alice is gonna
think I'm the one acting weird so yeah
there's there's all sorts of weird edge
cases there's all sorts of weird stuff
that could happen
it's definitely more complicated than
just the straight-up UTX I was in
Bitcoin yes it was like couldn't counter
will respond to bulb and then won't be
malicious and close the channel and then
say hey Alice yep
it's okay Bob Bob blames Carol Carol
says no was actually Bob from Alice's
point of view like whatever like
something got close there was a cost to
adding this HT you know there was a cost
to having me stuck with this hdl-c for
five hours write something on chain
happened so so like the thing is having
one hdl-c stuck for a few hours it's no
big deal
after five o'clock Alice just goes to
bombs like look well let's clear it
right you don't know are you if you knew
are you would have told me by now so
let's just get rid of this thing and
Bob's like yeah fine and they clear it
out so the idea is it's it's not a big
attack if you only have one of them it's
a you want some cost to performing that
and so if Bob closes the channel whether
its kara's fault or Bob's fault
alice is sort of like look well
something happened so someone's bearing
the cost for this so they're not going
to keep doing it
you needed he actually need hours
because Oh other attack let's say this
was for let's say these were both five
o'clock right and then Carol closes the
channel right at five o'clock grabs the
you know right before five o'clock Carol
grabs it you know close to the channel
uses are grabs it Bob then says oh shoot
there's our Alice is like no Alice
closes the channel right it right after
five and grabs her by by signing with
her key and above Bob screwed right
Bob's like shoot wait Carol just got the
money from me using our and then Alice
closes got the money for me using the
time out and I didn't get anything right
I lost the money on this side and I
didn't get the money on this side so Bob
just got Bob just had a huge loss there
so Bob really wants to make sure that
this is later like Alice can't get the
money until well after Carol can get the
money with the timeout function I'm
sorry that well after Bob can get his
money with the time yeah well they all
hold on Bob sets this time yes and Alice
sets this time
yeah he has to make sure his is earlier
and and continuing that right so if
Carol opens a channel if Carol makes an
HDL City today if she makes it at 3
o'clock or whatever I don't remember
what the defaults are and the different
like like I do it all on test net and so
in test net I do like five blocks
because who cares but I think in the
main net ones people are trying out they
do quite a bit more because it's better
to have your money stuck for a day than
to lose it I guess so so you can make
different time outs and stuff like that
okay
what else I'm basically done there's a
whole bunch of other cool things you can
do it and I'll I think I'll talk about
that next time yeah you can do cross
chain swaps so this is preview of after
great this channel and this channel do
not need to be on the same blockchain
totally fine for this to be Bitcoin has
to be like coin or this to be dogecoin
you know like it actually totally works
so that's kind of cool security so you
can monitor you want to monitor your
channels in case someone tries to rip
you off you can outsource that in a nice
way where you give it to a third party
and say hey I've got this channel watch
it for me not only that I've got a
channel watch it for me I'm not gonna
tell you what channel it is how much
money you have basically anything and
you can still protect it for me so
that's kind of cool you can anonymously
view that stuff case she'll sees I just
talked about dust and fees gets really
ugly there's a lot of cool stuff you can
do so I think that the schedule is I'll
talk about the rest of lightning on
Monday after Spring Break and then go
into discrete log contracts which is
another similar construction on the
Wednesday after ok any questions about
all this stuff
I'm sure yeah
miners miners Kim can make timeouts not
happen right if there's a lot of if
there's their coordinated they can say
we're just gonna not accept this
transaction till later so that's bad
yeah there's a there's there's all other
weird attack vectors the one that I
worry about most not most the one that I
worry about is if you make a backup of
your wallet and you restore it you lose
all your money so you make a backup here
at state two onto your USB stick and you
go home and you drop your laptop in the
pool and you're like shoot well good
thing I got my backup and then you were
well sorry you may come back up here at
work on your USB stick and then you keep
spending money and then you drop your
laptop in the pool and then you restore
from your USB stick to here and then you
try to broadcast this but you've already
revealed your private keys and so Bob's
just like what like that's red like you
you revealed it and then he takes all
the money so yeah don't make backups
it's like the the reason I worry about
it is it's very counterintuitive there's
nothing in the software that does this
right the software I can write like you
know don't make backups always only keep
this but you just copy the files and it
seems like the kind of thing people
might do and you know put warnings and
the readme is and stuff so that's kind
of a big risk so there's a lot of like
how do we make this safe how do and like
a lot of people criticize it like this
is too complicated there's like enormous
communities on the internet that hate
this and hate me and mmm go to our BTCC
don't like the lightning Network I don't
mean the other kind it's like well you
don't like it you don't to use it right
I'm just writing the software for free
for you guys but anyway but yeah and and
you know there's legitimate like this is
kind of complicated this might not it's
not gonna work for everything there's
all sorts of you know things that that
limit limits to this too